-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with George Lopez.
You alluded to one of your
co-stars in a way,
the great Cheech Marin.
-Cheech, yes, my boyhood hero.
Love Cheech and Chong.
You know, I went to his house
in Malibu and we made
some shrimp and stuff,
watching the sun come down.
And he's like,
"You want to smoke a joint?"
And I'm like..."Yes."
[ Laughter ]
But my tolerance isn't high.
So, we're on the roof
and we're smoking weed,
and it's going back and forth.
And then, you know, the sun is
coming down.
And he's like,
"Thanks for coming over."
And I get in my car,
and I'm looking at the gate.
And the gate looks like
it's opening.
So, I'm like, "Is it opening?"
[ Laughter ]
20 minutes later I hear...
And I roll the window down.
It's Cheech. He goes, "Hey, man,
you're too far from the gate.
Man, you got to pull forward."
[ Laughter ]
I was like 40 feet
from the gate.
[ Laughter ]
-I bet Cheech has to go out in
the driveway a fair amount.
-I'm pretty sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Here you guys are
back in the day.
-Oh, my God.
-Again, unnoticeable even.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And here you guys are now.
Look at that.
You also --
I want to shout out --
This is another legend
right here.
-That best.
-I mean, what's it like
to work with Rita Moreno again?
-Amazing.
-Again, here she is in
the original "Lopez."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And here she is again.
Can we just say with
all due respect to you,
with all due respect to Cheech,
no one's keeping it together
like Rita Moreno.
-Nobody is keeping it
together --
-No one is aging better than
Rita.
-I sure -- I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
She's 90 years old.
-Unbelievable.
-She slept with Elvis to make
Marlon Brando jealous.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is very -- I mean,
as things go,
that's pretty impressive.
-That's pretty impressive.
Also, I'm a conspiracy theorist.
Like Joe Biden --
I think everybody is Latino.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-When you take papers home,
Latino.
-Oh, interesting.
-I'll read them here, then I'll
finish them up at home.
[ Laughter ]
You always take things home.
-Hey, who are you -- Obviously,
we got Rita there.
We got Cheech there. Who's your
dream guest to be on the sitcom?
-It's got to be Jennifer Lopez.
I mean, come on. Jennifer Lopez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lopez vs. Lopez vs. Lopez.
-There you go.
-You talk about the Lopez way
on the show.
How would you describe for those
who don't know what
the Lopez way is?
-You know what?
I have been doing stand-up
a long time, and it's been
very kind to me.
I have a great life.
Where I came from,
the Lopez way is --
Seth, when there is
no other way.
-Uh-huh.
-And you still have to succeed,
the Lopez way.
-Well, there you go.
It's been working out alright
for you.
It's lovely to see you and your
family out on camera together.
Thanks so much for being here.
You guys, give it up
for George Lopez!
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Lopez vs Lopez" airs Friday
on NBC
and streams the next day
on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with Sadie Sink.